hot breath and how did their
relationship grow with george and what
was he like well he said
any time he says look any time um
because of when we got towards the i see
the sign that said departures and i said
this
this is going to end really soon and so
i said you know what would be your best
piece of advice i may never see you
again
he goes i hope not you know but he meant
i hope so
right right i hope you won't i hope not
you won't see me again
whatever right so he said uh i said what
would be your best piece of advice he
said there's a line across it
that sounds like a metaphor george uh
give me something that's more concrete
you mean i don't want like is that does
he mean touchdown or line crossing
or what does he mean exactly he said he
said you ever read the newspaper watch
the news and call
[__] and i said all the time he said
make that your comedy
but make it funny here's a trick raise
the bridge
and that was that means raise your
eyebrows when you're delivering
something that you're angry about
and it'll change it from you being angry
and judging maybe this audience's ideals
to this is absurd i don't understand it
i'm confused
interesting jon stewart uses it all the
time or did it use it all the time in
yeah on the daily show he'd go this is
crazy why are they doing this
i find i have a habit of doing this so
it's
just raise your eyebrows instead and
perceive differently yeah watch
who bill maher struggles with doing that
he tries to
he's like he often gets into weird
twitch